once again it's crunch time on Capitol
Hill as lawmakers debate the fate of
daca and look for a way to keep the
government open past a Friday midnight
deadline Senator Marco Rubio joins us
now from Capitol Hill to discuss those
and a lot of other issues thanks for
joining us senator Rubio let's get right
to it the topic of the day is this
immigration impasse once again and for
our viewers out there are you more
attuned to the the current Durbin Graham
version of the immigration bill or would
it be closer to the Republicans who are
called the more hardline people like Tom
cotton or senator Perdue well I'm not I
don't know the details of the Graham
Durban proposal other than what's been
expressed in the media I haven't seen
those details I can tell you what I
believe in I believe we do have to build
a wall and improve our overall security
like at airports with entry/exit I
believe we should end the diversity
lottery I've been saying that for about
five years I believe that we should move
toward a merit-based system of
immigration I believe that we should
figure out a way like the president has
to deal with people that find themselves
or many of the people to find themselves
now under a daca designation and I think
the big debate has been how do you put
all that together and the way I view it
is the president's number-one priority
is border security the Democrats are
insisting on daca and so in order to get
it passed under this sort of framework
that were in now each side is going to
have to get something but what else gets
in there is what the debate has been
about and so I support ending the
diversity lottery I along I think we
should admit people to the United States
based on what they're gonna contribute
to the United States and that's why I've
long called for a merit-based system of
immigration irrespective of what country
here coming from it shouldn't be country
based it should be person based
absolutely and Senator Beck in 2015 you
gave a speech or a it's a back and forth
with Hannity at CPAC and you said I've
learned my lesson on immigration and
your point was that we have to do
enforcement first before we can get to
the other parts you said
and that was obviously because of the
gang of eight that went down in flames
but the gang of eight now it's a gang of
six and you have Lindsey Graham out
there who today said we need different
partners willing partners in the White
House well what of that I mean the White
House is the White House the president
ran on the wall and enforcement and he's
willing to do daca too well just about
anything we pass here you're gonna have
to have him sign it so that's the only
partner at the end of the day that's
going to matter is what the president
will sign and by the way the lesson I
referred to in 2015 was more than just
border security first it was with a
step-by-step approach versus a
comprehensive one on what you try to do
all these things together it says you're
seeing now you're only talking about
five things and they can't put it
together
so that's why I've long believed that
you start with security first that's
something everybody should agree on I
don't know why anybody would argue that
we shouldn't secure our border and
enforce our immigration laws and then
you moved into modernization which are
things like making it merit-based or
getting rid of the diversity lottery
basically going to a person based
immigration system as opposed to a
country or family based one aren't they
doing they are doing amnesty at the same
time not not everybody but they are
doing 800 thousand at the same time so
they're kind of doing and a smaller
version of what you guys tried to do in
2013 and that obviously didn't work out
well and the president's still willing
to give that's the point I mean
everybody involved in this negotiation
is saying we understand that we're gonna
deal with the daca situation but you've
got to do strong enforcement that's
going to happen and one of the
differences between now and 2013 is you
have someone at the White House that
people trust is actually going to do it
that's a big dynamic shift from where we
stood at this time in 2013 arguing about
whether or not the enforcement would
even happen even if we passed the law
people would argue that it wouldn't
happen so that's a difference are you
for it that's an important set of goals
and all of that to come in so I think
keeping the nuclear family is one thing
I think allowing people to claim their
parents or other relatives is not
something that I'd support and and I to
me that's part of moving away from the
family based system and towards the
merit-based system let's talk about what
Jeff Flake is saying tomorrow another
one of your colleagues got a lot of
charges first strip first Trump's a
racist which I assume you don't agree
with that's what Durbin is saying you
don't agree with that right
I've never seen him say or do anything
in front of me that leads me to believe
that you know people have a right to
have whatever opinion they want but but
I certainly have never viewed him that
way yeah I mean I don't know how you sit
down in a room with someone one day and
two days later said well he's a racist
but but now Jeff Flake is giving it
speech tomorrow where he's comparing
Trump's treatment of the press to Joseph
Stalin's
and of course Stalin the Great Purge 20
million to 60 million deaths attributed
to him how do we get here senator well I
think look I don't agree with everything
the president does I bet you you don't
agree with everything the president does
but one of the things that is happening
is exaggeration just like the President
does things from time to time that I
don't agree with or would have done
differently I think the reaction to it
is often very exaggerated I hadn't given
the speech yet so we'll see what he says
tomorrow but I don't think there's any
comparison not just between this
president but any American public figure
with Joseph Stalin but again I don't
know if that's what he's gonna say in a
speech I mean he hasn't given it yet
yeah well he's teased it well let's talk
about what you want to do to prevent
foreign governments from interfering in
American elections you're teaming up
with Chris Van Hollen a Democrat and
what is your goal and what do you intend
to do so there's clearly a Russia
element to it because there's no doubt
the Russians tried to interfere in our
election by the way in my view not
simply to favor a candidate I may have
been what they felt like at the end but
for much of it it was just to sow
discord but my bigger problem we can't
do about that we can only deal with
what's happened in the past
prospectively or you know looking about
retro actively but prophetically the
biggest threat to America's electoral
system and quite frankly America at
large is not Russia it's China
it's China's has basically infiltrated
its way into all of our technologies
across the supply chain they make
anything the Russians can do look like
child's play and that includes stealing
secrets that includes influencing
individuals in American government
through a lot of different methods and
that includes potentially interfering in
an election so I think the biggest
threat moving forward is not the
Russians it's actually the Chinese they
are much larger with a lot more
capability and a lot more money and
that's one of the things I thought about
when
involved in this legislation and any
thoughts about this New York Times piece
that just came out tonight that the
administration is going to be reviewing
possible plans to expand our military
response with nuclear weapons to
potential cyberattacks on water
communications other essential services
that would basically shut down the power
grid etcetera yeah so I promise you that
there's gonna be overreaction to that as
well some of the same things I told you
exaggeration you'll see headlines that
say Trump wants a nuclear attack because
of hacking that that's not what this is
about by the way this doctrine is
actually not new it's just been expanded
and now of course when made public the
bigger thing about this is you talk
about some of these attacks we're
talking about things that would knock
planes out of the sky kill patients and
hospitals wipe out millions of dollars
from bank accounts paralyze our electric
grid I mean I'm talking about massive
loss of life if if the kinds of attacks
that are being tried to anticipate it
here are there are the attacks that
happen people need to know ahead of time
if you do this we're not going to have a
series of town hall meetings to talk
about why did this happen this is what
the response is going to be country's
know what the response is going to be if
they launch a nuclear attack against us
they need to know what that response is
going to be if they launch a massive
life-threatening cyber or irregular
attack as I think a lot of countries
that may not have a nuclear capability
or may have a small nuclear capability
have the ability to expand into this
territory we don't do a better job of
protecting ourselves
senator Rubio thanks so much for
spending some time with us tonight hope
to see you soon Thanks